good morning the Senate Committee on
health education labor and pensions will
please come to order I want to welcome
everyone to the latest in our ongoing
series of hearings focusing on
retirement security I'm told this is the
seventh or the eighth hearing huh this
is the seventh hearing that we've had on
this over the last couple of years today
we're going to take a closer look at the
question how much do families need to
save for retirement well I guess maybe
I'm about to find that out i guess i had
a distant future as an aside but i
already know from my constituents that
the dream of a secure retirement is
growing fainter whether it is a young
family starting to pay off student loan
debt save for the kids education and put
something aside for their own retirement
or a 65 year old nurse finally eligible
to stop working americans are fearful
about whether they'll have enough money
to live on when they when they retire
that's why we're starting this new
Congress by focusing on how we can help
people save for retirement today we're
going to hear testimony about how much
people need to save what's holding them
back and how we can help them build a
nest egg as a starting point I think we
need to keep in mind that kind of the
bottom line people simply are not saving
enough I've said this before but the
retirement income deficit that is the
difference between what people need for
their retirement in the future and what
they actually have now has been
estimated to be as high as six point six
trillion dollars
half of all Americans have less than ten
thousand dollars in savings so these are
very disturbing and frightening numbers
when people run out of money when they
get old they see their living standard
decline they need more and more on the
social safety net squeezing government
costs again at all levels so it comes
back on taxpayers again so we need to do
more to help American families cope with
this looming crisis hardworking
Americans deserve to be able to rest and
take a vacation spend more time with the
grandkids when they get older but to do
so they need to have better
opportunities opportunities to save
prior to retirement we've always said
there needs to be a three-legged stool
that was social security pensions and
savings now in Social Security provided
a base but it was never meant to be a
full retirement system it was to be one
leg of that stool and then secondly
people my generation and before counted
on defined benefit pensions I always say
that when I first came to Congress one
out of every two Americans had a pension
that were an annuity that would last
until the day they died defined-benefit
today it's one out of five and getting
less third people would would have
savings but again these savings are not
enough as I said half of all Americans
at less than ten thousand dollars and
again although many employers now offer
retirement savings plan such as 401 KS
again those plans were designed again to
supplement supplement traditional
pensions not replace them so savings
rates are just too low and a very few
401k plans offer people an easy
cost-effective way to convert their
savings into a steady stream of lifetime
retirement income and so I look forward
to hearing about some of the innovative
innovative ways that companies like T
achraf and fidelity and others are
helping people to cope with these
challenges so I'm a true believer that
we need to restore the three-legged
stool that starts with rebuilding the
pension system
and after all these hearings we released
a report last September called the
retirement crisis and a plan to solve it
and we put out some ideas and
suggestions I have been working with the
senator Enzi a lot on this over the past
several months and his staff and again
we've heard time and again in this
committee that employers especially
small businesses just can't do pensions
they're too complex they're too risky
they have to take it out of their bottom
line to hire the people to run it they
have a fiduciary responsibility and so
that's why we need a new plan that's
simplified that's privately run that
takes the onus off of the employers and
makes it easy for people to actually put
money away for a like a divine benefit
I'd like to say that our plan is that
we've been working on has the benefits
of a specs of defined benefit and
defined contribution so I'm making this
a as the chairman of this committee I'm
making this a top priority for this
committee to to look at and to to
actually bring something to fruition
hopefully in this Congress with that
I'll turn to Senator Alexander thanks
mr. chairman and I want to applaud you
and Senator Enzi for your focus
consistent focus on on on this lots of
times one of the most useful functions
of of the United States Senate is to put
a spotlight on the right question and
then explore toward some good solutions
so I I believe you've clearly put the
spotlight on the right question our
workers saving enough for retirement and
your focus on the retirement income
deficit I also appreciate the
even-handed way you've approached these
hearings you have your own suggested
idea but you've opened you've opened the
hearings to witnesses from all
directions and give that gives us a
chance really to test senator Harkins
proposals as well as
other proposals and hopefully come to a
good conclusion I think the witness for
being here and I told them earlier I
look forward to hearing what they have
what they have to say of course we
currently have the mandatory retirement
plan my instinct my preference would be
to explore what we knew what we need to
do to beef up or strengthen our
voluntary retirement plans we read
regularly about troubles that both
corporate and union defined benefit
plans have need to be careful in the
changing world that we have where
businesses aren't like businesses were
40 or 50 years ago we're in a global
marketplace with rapidly changing
companies employers look different than
employers did some time ago we have to
be very careful about decisions we make
here because we're talking about tens of
millions of individuals and we're
talking about hundreds of thousands of
businesses who might be affected by
whatever whatever we do on the subject
of I would like for us to be careful as
we go through this in about placing new
mandates on business enterprises in
America and I'd like to use an example
or two to suggest why as we I was
visited not long ago by franchise group
that owns 20 fast-food restaurants in DC
Virginia and Maryland they employ 542
people now here's what if they're trying
to make a profit which is their goal in
business they start out with the 6.2
percent social security medicare taxes
they have a menu labeling mandate that's
another thousand dollars per restaurant
for each one dollar increase in the
minimum wage mandate that's nearly
25,000 dollars per year they have paid
sick leave mandates I'm not relitigate
in any of those issues I'm just saying
if you're operating a business that's
those are some of the mandates you start
out paying
and we have to be careful about thinking
about new ones and then there's the
health care mandates that are coming
that are coming on again not to
relitigate them but if I were the owner
of that 20 fast-food restaurants they
tell me that that they offer health care
to their 542 employees but only 34 take
it if if nothing changed next year that
is of the health care law didn't go into
effect they would still be spending
ninety four thousand dollars on health
care under the health care law if they
opted to pay the penalty they'll be
spending a million dollars instead of 94
that exceeds their net profit for the
year 2013 if they were decide themselves
to continue to offer health care their
cost would be between 400 thousand and
one point four million dollars you can
apply the same sort of reasoning and
statistics to an even smaller company
and come out with similar results which
is that if we want to create an
environment for the largest number of
new jobs in America so people going to
have the largest incomes so that they
can then have more money to spend on
saving for retirement we need to be very
careful and circumspect about any new
cost or mandate on existing businesses
for is it in the case of the health care
law they these same restaurants are
reducing the number of employees they
have and they're reducing the number of
full-time employees people who work more
than 30 hours therefore they won't make
as much money therefore they may not
have as much to to retire so my point is
that number one I think the Chairman is
doing a terrific job of moving us toward
the right question he's offered a very
thoughtful solution of his own he's
invited witnesses all across the board
that should educate us and my hope would
be that as we look toward a solution
that we're very circumspect about
imposing any new mandates on business
enterprises in the country because I
think they're likely to be
self-defeating reduce the number of
full-time jobs and reduce the level of
incomes that people have from which they
could say Thank You mr. chairman
Thank You senator Alexander and we have
an excellent panel of witnesses today at
people that have done a lot of work in
and thinking about retirement and they
have a lot to share with this committee
I I thank them all for for being here I
will introduce a couple than and then
I'll turn to summon to Senator Warren
for other introductions first we'll hear
from Ed ma slander senior managing
director at tiaa-cref mr mulliner has
been with Tia craft for more than 28
years and has extensive experience
working with plan sponsors in the
academic research medical and cultural
fields we have cindy council president
of the Women's Institute for a secure
retirement wiser I think it's called I
was privileged to speak to your group
just not too long ago miss council has
been working with women for years to
equip them with the knowledge and tools
they need to take charge of their
finances and prepare for retirement now
I'd recognize senator Warren for
purposes of introduction of two other
witnesses if we have senator Warren
thank you very much mr. chairman I want
to introduce Julia McCarthy she was born
and raised in Massachusetts and she now
lives in southborough mass with her
husband and her two sons she is an
executive vice president in the
workplace investing division of fidelity
investments fidelity is a homegrown
Massachusetts company that has become a
worldwide leader providing investment
management retirement planning and other
financial services to more than 20
million individuals and institutions ms
mccarthy has been a leader in that
company developing a data based analysis
of retirement strategies i'm proud to
have ms mccarthy here today representing
fidelity and i know she will offer
valuable insights to this committee i'm
also very pleased to be able to
introduce dr. Bridget mad rien who is
the eighth the Aetna professor of public
policy and corporate management at the
Harvard Kennedy School she's also taught
at the University of Pennsylvania
hortons school the University of Chicago
graduate school of business and the
Harvard
versity economics department dr. mad
Rian's research focuses on household
savings and investment behavior she
received her PhD in economics from the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
and studied economics as an
undergraduate at Brigham Young
University she's a recipient of the
National Academy of Social Insurance
dissertation prize and a two-time
recipient of the tiaa-cref paules
Samuelson award for scholarly research
on lifelong financial security she is
one of the country's foremost experts on
investment behavior and I'm very pleased
to have her here I know that she will be
very helpful to this committee welcome
very good thank you very much senator
and thank you over again for being here
your statements will be made a part of
the record in their entirety I was read
them over last evening they're very good
I would ask we'll start with mr. Mars
Lander we'll just go down if you could
do a summary of your statement so that
we could get into more of a exchange I'd
appreciate that so if you take maybe
five to seven minutes or something like
that to just give us a summary of your
statement of appreciate it mr mulliner
Thank You chairman Harkin ranking member
Alexander members of the committee
thanks for the opportunity to appear
today to discuss way as Americans can
achieve a financially secure retirement
I am at misano I'm seeing senior
managing director of GRFs institutional
client services organization TI CREF was
found in nearly a century ago to assist
college professors with achieving
financial security and retirement today
we manage over 500 billion dollars in
assets for 3.7 million individuals that
we serve in the educational research
medical and cultural communities we do
believe the nation is facing retirement
security crisis their traditional
three-legged stool consisting of
pensions Social Security and personal
savings has become increasingly unsteady
retirement has become more of a
do-it-yourself proposition where a large
part of an individual's retirement
security defense depends on defined
contribution retirement plans as a
result achieving a comfortable
retirement has become a source of
increasing concern for America
roading confidence in their ability to
do so GI cuffs experience has provided
us with a unique perspective on the
retirement challenges America faces the
higher education community our core
market has never depended on defined
benefit plans and instead since 1918 is
relied only on defined contribution
plans to provide retirement security and
employers have funded those plans to
ensure that participants have adequate
retirement savings as a result we found
that our clients generally are more
confident about retirement prospects
when compared to the rest of us
population a survey conducted by our
Institute found that 75% of higher
education employees are either very
confident or somewhat confident in their
retirement income prospects compared
with only forty-nine percent of us
workers in general same survey found
that eighty eight percent of higher
education employees are currently saving
for retirement of these sixty percent
have tried to figure out just how much
they need to save for a secure
retirement I'd like to highlight a few
things practices that we encourage that
we believe it contributed to these
results first the proliferation of
defined contribution plan model means
that saving for retirement has become
more of an individual responsibility but
for the model to be successful it has to
be in our experience a shared
responsibility while defined
contribution plans enable workers to
save for retirement many eligible
employees still don't participate in
those who do have a difficult time
saving the ten to fifteen percent of
their annual income that most financial
experts agree is necessary for secure
retirement for this reason it's
extremely important that employers
recognize that attaining retirement
savings goals is a shared responsibility
between employers and employees and
accordingly employer contributions
should be a foundation of any retirement
plan that said employers cannot be
expected fully to fund a retirement plan
and should also ensure that matching
programs are in place to further and
sense individual participation in the
plan part of the success of our program
is that there was always been an
employer contribution which is part of
that shared responsibility it's
not uncommon for our plan sponsors to
contribute a flat percentage to an
individual's retirement plan over and
above any match that they might offer
employer contributions demonstrate to
employees that they value that the
employer value saving for retirement and
care about employees future and it can
also be a competitive advantage in the
quest for workers and talents the next
point I'd like to make is that while
getting employees to contribute is an
important step we also have to recognize
that workers have to make complex
decisions about how much they should
save and how to invest those savings
however the pervasive lack of financial
literacy across our nation often means
that a lot of people are not equipped
for that task we believe it's important
to offer clients tools that can assist
them with making these decisions such
tools include user-friendly online
programs advice access to advisors and
comprehensive objective third-party
advice programs it's important that each
of these tools ensure that the guidance
they provide is one holistic taking into
account all source of a worker savings
to is affordable and accessible to all
employees not only those with high
balances consider savings rates
retirement age asset allocation fund
selection and the probability of
reaching goals includes information on
how to structure invests and invest
retirement income and is delivered by
firms and advisors who take fiduciary
responsibility for the advice that they
provide and finally well there's been a
lot of attention paid to the savings the
accumulation phase there's been less of
a focus on the drawdown phase when
people are spending the money they have
saved during retirement due to our
increasing lifespans as well as concerns
surrounding Social Security the movement
away from traditional defined-benefit
plans the drawdown phase will and should
become a greater focus of the retirement
security discussion GI craft sees the
issue of ensuring that people do not
outlive their retirement savings as
among the most pressing issues in
retirement income security today a 2011
report by the Government Accountability
Office encouraged annuities ation as an
important means of addressing the issue
it's crucial that those who are saving
for retirement receive information not
just about how much they've got in
savings but also about how that
accumulation translates into income at
retirement gif includes a retirement
income projection on all of our clients
quarterly statements that provides an
estimate of what their monthly income
would be a retirement while also
providing information about how they
could improve the prospects of this
income projection by saving more we
believe that providing this key piece of
additional information assists in
reframing the conversation about
retirement savings by putting the focus
on income as opposed to strictly on
accumulating assets based on this
experience trf supported the lifetime
income disclosure act which was
introduced in the last Congress this
proposal would have required all
retirement plan participants to receive
at least annually an illustration of how
their current accumulation would
translate into income at retirement to
conclude as the committee considers the
issue of retirement security and
improving retirement savings among
Americans we urge you to look at ways of
strengthening the means by which
Americans can achieve a secure
retirement some of which I've outlined
here we're confident that policymakers
and the private sector can work together
to address these challenges on find
solutions that guarantee that all
Americans can attain a financially
secure retirement grf is ready to assist
in any way that we can as we work
towards this shared goal thank you again
for providing the opportunity to testify
and I look forward to your questions
Julia well thank you mr. Marsh lander is
very very very good testimony mr.
McCarthy chairman Harkin ranking member
Alexander and members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to be here
today my name is Julia McCarthy I'm an
executive vice president at fidelity
investments within the workplace
investing business we have the privilege
of serving more than 18 million American
workers from more than 22,000 employers
fidelity takes very seriously the
responsibility to ensure that workers
know how to save how much to and say
and how to invest for retirement I'd
like to thank you for bringing attention
to the issue of retirement security and
more importantly the importance of
insuring American workers are saving
enough for retirement we share your
concern that many Americans are not
prepared for retirement yet we know from
our data what savings behaviors work for
a majority of workers the steps are
straightforward enroll in your workplace
plan the earlier the better save at the
highest levels possible increase your
contribution rate is your salary grows
invest in a diversified asset mix and
own your plan stick with it stay engaged
and avoid taking out loans or cashing
out when you change jobs that said we
know that savings is not always simple
I'd like to focus on three areas which
help people increase their savings but
can be improved to help Americans reap
the full power of their benefits the
first one is inertia while the results
of the Pension Protection Act have been
impressive more needs to be done to
harness the power of automatic plan
features and defaults the default rate
for many plans is too low the current
safe harbor rules for 401 k plans start
at a three percent default rate starting
at a six percent rate would give workers
a significant leg up on savings our data
shows that 61 percent of workers who
auto enroll do not change their default
rate in opt-out rates are virtually
identical regardless of the three
percent or the six percent starting
point let's give people the advantage of
saving more and put the power of inertia
to work for them number two is
maximizing savings through automated
programs recognizing inertia and the
need to save there are programs to
leverage the additional feature of the
pension protection act that
automatically increase contribution
levels annual increase programs are the
primary way workers are increasing their
contributions our data shows that close
to one-third of all contribution
increases last year and the plans we
administer were attributed to an annual
increase program unfortunately these
programs are underutilized where only
eleven percent of employers are offering
them
it may feel a bit onerous but when
aligned with an annual salary increase
these programs can increase savings
while minimizing the impact to take home
pay number three and critically
important is education and guidance more
than ever workers are responsible for
saving and planning for their retirement
they need help understanding a range of
financial topics from the most basic
information about how to enroll and how
much they should save to the more
complex topics such as proper asset
allocation in retirement income planning
workers who receive guidance take action
and have better outcomes our data shows
that workers who engage in a retirement
planning session as an example either
online or on the phone increase their
deferral rates on average by five to six
percentage points one theme that is a
constant in all of our research is that
the majority of workers want and need
help workers also need a simple way to
gauge their savings process last fall
fidelity released new research on hbase
savings guidelines these guidelines
serve as a framework for establishing
retirement savings goals as workers
progress through their careers their
salary times a factor of X can be one of
the measures used to assess their
retirement savings progress we found
that a simple to understand savings
target is a framework that resonates
with both workers and employers and we
believe this approach will be helpful
for people who switch jobs frequently
and who may have a number of retirement
accounts that's making it even more
difficult to evaluate one saving
strategy in closing there is a path to
retirement security for most Americans
but the road is not always an easy one
many key constituencies have a role in
ensuring success first workers need to
take an active role in saving and
managing for their financial future
employers need more flexibility in the
rules and regulations to design benefit
plans which meet the diverse needs of
their workforce without risk of
fiduciary liability and increased
coverage costs third service providers
like fidelity need to continue to
innovate around how to help plan sponsor
is optimized their benefit programs and
service participants based on their
needs and last we asked policymakers to
consider a variety of ideas to improve
retirement savings outcomes some
examples include increasing the default
deferral rate in sending more plans to
adopt auto features protecting and
promoting the availability of education
and guidance modernizing and simplifying
the current regulatory framework to
allow for more innovation exploring new
ways to help incent younger workers to
save for their retirement and partnering
with schools and other organizations to
help ensure all students have access to
quality financial literacy fidelity is
committed to partnering with you mr.
chairman and ranking member Alexander
and members of your committee to work
towards solving these critically
important issues I sincerely thank you
for the opportunity to be here today and
share our perspective and experience in
helping Americans safe retirement I look
forward to your questions thank you very
much miss McCarthy and now Miss on cyl
sorry good morning chairman Harkin
senator Alexander and the other
distinguished members of the committee
we appreciate the opportunity to be here
today to discuss retirement saving by
American workers and to ensure that
committee members recognize the
significant retirement risk that women
face particularly the millions of women
who are on the cusp of retirement my
name is Cindy hounsell and president of
the Women's Institute for secure
retirement for 17 years we've been
trying to help women educators and
policymakers understand the important
issues surrounding women's retirement
income our primary mission is financial
education and capability providing women
with the crucial skills and information
they need to avoid poverty in retirement
wiser in the United States
administration on Aging also operate the
national education and resource center
on women in retirement planning we
commend the committee for examining
adequacy of retirement savings because
this comes at a time when 61 percent of
americans aged 44 to 75 fear running out
of
tireman assets more than they feared
death women are among the most worried
about saving and their financial
security in retirement and rightly so
they live longer they have less
retirement income divorce and widowhood
have significant negative consequences
for their financial well-being current
discussions about tax reform would lead
us to expect the policy makers would use
the process as an opportunity to
strengthen the retirement system and
improve its effectiveness we believe
that much can be accomplished by
strengthening and building on our
existing retirement programs such as
Social Security employer-sponsored plans
financially innovative products
incentives for longer work and increase
financial education and planning every
year there's new research and literature
showing that American workers are not
saving enough the Employee Benefit
Research Institute's retirement security
projection model for 2012 shows that
forty-four percent of baby boomers and
Gen Xers won't have enough retirement
income to cover even basic retirement
expenses and uninsured health costs when
looking just at the Gen Xers with a
shortfall the average savings deficit
for a single female is a little over a
hundred thirty-three thousand dollars
that's the additional amount that a
single female would on average need to
save by age 65 to eliminate her
shortfall the recent economic crisis has
made it even more difficult below
contribution rates and lack of
understanding of the need for a
comprehensive retirement strategy means
inadequate income for the rest of your
life these issues are compounded for
women in addition to living longer older
women are more likely to have costly
chronic medical conditions and need
long-term institutional care further
older women are more like to be likely
to be single at some point in their
lives which puts them at a higher risk
for poverty and it's a cruel irony at
the latest stage of life many women
become poor for the first time in their
lives today the rate of poverty for
women aged 65 and over is close to
eleven percent I in my testimony I have
a lot more numbers but what I'd like to
just point out is that of those numbers
once you get two single women for
African American women almost a third or
poor and for Hispanic women it's
forty-four percent which is just
enormous another twist on this is that
women also work fewer years because
they're the family primary caregivers
and caregiving can have serious
financial consequences a recent studies
showed that caregivers lost about three
hundred four thousand dollars in wages
Social Security and private pension
losses and another problem is older
women taking in their grown children and
their grandchildren almost twenty
percent of the grandparents responsible
for grandchildren who live with them are
living in poverty in the workplace
there's better news but it still varies
by ethnicity and racial groups and black
women were the most likely to work for
an employer with a plan while Latinas
were the least likely however the gender
gap is a continuing factor and another
ebury report suggests that while women
in the aggregate had been closing the
retirement participation rate over the
last decade they've slipped a little
because of the reception recession sorry
the reality of today's retirement
landscape is already mentioned is do it
yourself do it right or live at or below
the edge of poverty for the rest of your
life that's the reality for a lot of
people and that slice of the pie keeps
getting bigger and bigger the nature of
today's system of individual
responsibility demands financial
capability we need to help people with
these issues and a lot of the
suggestions that are made are helpful
for people if you work in a large
company but for those who are in smaller
companies like what you're talking about
senator Alexander people just don't have
that level of education and literacy
women along with their male counterparts
tend to lack basic retirement financial
knowledge and it's often the reason why
they make serious financial mistakes
women need the best information an
opportunity to access information to
ensure that they don't make these
mistakes experience and research shows
that relevant financial information from
trusted resources can dramatically in
total net worth by nearly a third for
those even with the lowest income and up
to eighteen percent for those with
moderate income so what can we do one of
our key initiatives as I mentioned the
National Resource Center that we operate
with us administration on Aging provides
programs in communities and these
interventions leverage strategic
partnerships not only with other
nonprofit aging organizations but
business federal agencies and financial
services groups so first of all before I
get into my long list which is in my
testimony and I won't read that to you
at this point one of the most important
things that we think needs to be done is
supporting increased economic and
financial security for women of all ages
would be to to strengthen the Social
Security system and we're happy to see
that the white paper that the chairman
has issued has a plan to strengthen
Social Security and another one of my
favorite provisions which has been
talked about in this city for about 20
years is to help caregivers by including
a provision in Social Security for
caregiving credits so there are many
programs around that help at-risk
populations what we need to do is start
working with these models that really
know we know work and promote them on a
larger scale many of these programs help
people avoid dependence on government
programs and conclusion I'd like to say
thank you for letting me hammer home the
risks for women in retirement and I'd
like to just say finally that there's no
single solution I've been hearing
everybody wait till we get the perfect
plan there is no perfect plan we already
know where the problems are what the
challenges are we need to target those
segments of the population there are
range of solutions and most of all we
need to continue to build on what's
working make it better and just realize
that there are a lot of Americans out
there who are just trying to achieve
basic financial stability thank you
thank you very much miss on sale now dr.
Matt Greene
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you today and share my thoughts on
how we can strengthen America's
retirement savings system I'm Bridget
may dream the Aetna professor of public
policy and corporate management at the
Harvard University john f kennedy school
of government and i've spent the last 15
years studying employer-sponsored
savings plans and the types of policy
interventions and plan design features
that can improve savings outcomes
there's much concern in both academic
and policy circles about whether our
current private defined contribution
retirement savings system can adequately
meet the retirement income needs of
individuals although the current system
has several shortcomings there are
several sensible steps that can be taken
to improve outcomes for individuals with
throughout without substantially
increasing the costs or risks to
employers my early research on automatic
enrolment documented how small changes
in plan design can have a large impact
on savings outcomes this research
provided the impetus for the measures
incorporated in the Pension Protection
Act of 2006 that encourage employers to
adopt automatic enrollment as part of
their employer-sponsored savings plans
there are many other measures that can
further strengthen the private defined
contribution saving system in the US and
my remarks I will highlight for
shortcomings of the current system and
suggest potential avenues for change the
first short coming of the current system
is participation less than half of
private-sector workers participate in an
employer sponsored retirement plan low
participation is a particular problem
for employees in small firms many of
which do not even offer a savings plan
policy initiatives that encourage and
facilitate the automatic savings of
employees and small firms are a key step
to improving outcomes in a defined
contribution retirement system to such
proposals are the widely endorsed
automatic IRA and the US Senate help
committee USA retirement funds both
would create a simple and low-cost
mechanism for small employers to make
contributions to retirement savings
accounts for their employees through
payroll deduction the second short
coming of the current system is that
those workers who do participate in the
defined contribution retirement savings
plan too often have contribution rates
that are
low savings plans need to be structured
to encourage higher participant
contributions let me suggest three easy
ways to do so one changed the structure
of the employer match a typical savings
plan employer match is 50% up to six
percent of pay such a match cost the
employer three percent of pay for
employees contributing six percent or
more to the plan and gives employees an
incentive to save six percent of pay
consider instead a match of thirty
percent up to ten percent of pay this
would cost the employer three percent of
pay for every employee contributing at
or above ten percent to the plan but
this match gives employees of financial
incentive to save at least ten percent
of pay but at no increased cost to the
employer to encourage employers to adopt
a higher default contribution rate under
automatic enrollment the widespread
adoption of automatic enrolment
following the Pension Protection Act of
2006 has been a clear victory for public
policy but the typical default
contribution rate is three percent a
rate that falls well short of what most
need to save for retirement yet we know
from extensive research that many
employees will persist at the default
the solution is easy set a higher
default contribution rate one concern is
that a higher default contribution rate
will encourage more employees to opt out
of savings plan participation altogether
in my own research I have found that few
employees object to hire automatic
enrollment default contribution rates of
five or six percent in companies that
match at least to that level three more
aggressive automatic contribution
escalation even though the pension
protection act automatic contribution
increased bass line calls for a one
percent increase in contribution rates
each year there's no reason that
employers could not escalate employee
contribution rates more quickly say a
two percent or even three percent a year
research shows that few employees opt
out of contribution escalation even with
more aggressive annual increases note
that these three approaches to
increasing employee contributions are
not mutually exclusive and indeed a
combination of these approaches could be
particularly powerful a third short
coming of the current system is leakage
many individuals take money out of their
account before retirement for other
purposes this is a serious problem and
one that has been largely under
the radar screen recent studies by the
GAO the employees at the Federal Reserve
and the IRS and by the private company
hello wallet all estimate that there is
a sizable amount of leakage from the
retirement saving system most
significantly due to pre-retirement cash
distributions after employees chain
change jobs moreover survey results from
fidelity investments in the Boston
research group find that fifty-five
percent of employees who have taken a
pre-retirement cash distribution from
their defined contribution savings plan
later regret having done so the reality
is that defined contribution savings
plans are not used solely to fund
retirement from many they serve as an
all-purpose savings vehicle because of
this the recommended contribution rate
to these accounts should reflect not
only what is needed to successfully fund
retirement but what will in all
likelihood be withdrawn from the plan
before retirement as well this suggests
that policy should either encourage
contribution rates that are above those
needed solely to fund retirement or
policy should limit the extent to which
individuals can take pre-retirement
distributions from these accounts a
final short coming of the current system
is that most employer savings plans do
not offer employees an easy way to
transform their retirement wealth into
retirement income through an
annuitization option if retirees want an
annuitized income stream of up above and
beyond social security they are left to
contend with the private market on their
own trying to evaluate a product with
which they have little experience and
whose purchase will consume a
substantial fraction of their wealth the
end result is that annuitization rates
are very low employers provide several
several valuable services to their
employees when it comes to the
investment options in their savings
plans they evaluate the many available
alternatives and select a few options
that are best suited to their employees
needs and they are able to offer
employees lower-cost investment options
than the employees would have access to
individually through economies of scale
having employers perform the same
function for retirement income options
would be a valuable service to many
current and former employees but
employers currently have little
incentive to do so our defined
contribution retirement
system is not perfect but there are
several things we can do to make it
substantively better in conclusion first
we can increase coverage by creating an
easy and low-cost mechanism for small
employers to use so that employees at
these firms can benefit from the ease of
payroll deduction to fund a retirement
savings account second we can encourage
employers to structure their savings
plans in ways that promote higher
employee contribution rates third we can
limit leakage from retirement savings
plans and forth we can encourage the
adoption of implant and nuit ii options
thank you thank you dr. Madren now now
start a round of five minute questions
at dr. Madren I just want you to know
that we are looking at the whole
Leakey's problem and will this is
something that I've become more and more
aware of and hopefully this committee
will be looking at this shortly on that
hole on the leaky tissue let me just ask
you though in this plan that we sort of
rolled out last year this us a
retirement plan a key open issue is what
the contribution rate should be those
who have been working and developing
this plan has thought about it not as a
not like a Social Security where it's an
even match between employer and employee
this is mostly on employees to put in a
contribution with some very low
threshold employer match and then
allowing an employer to raise that match
if they want to as an employment
incentive so one employer might provide
one and a half percent another employer
might say well come to work for me will
do two and a half percent so you could
use that as employment incentive for for
employers but what have you ever thought
about what if we move ahead in this area
what should the contribution rate be
when we default people into the plan
that's an excellent question and I'd
encourage the committee to think not in
terms of a single default contribution
rate but perhaps a differentiated
alternative so when Senator Alexander
was talking about the the small
restaurant chain my guess is that a lot
of the employees working at companies
like that are younger they're they're
teenagers it's their first job and for
them a lower contribution rate might
make sense you know three percent of pay
five percent of pay whereas if you're
looking at someone who's a bit older and
this is their full-time job and they're
going to be working there for a while
the appropriate default contribution
rate for them might be substantially
higher we know from investors psychology
that individuals when they think about
saving think in terms of round numbers
multiples of five five percent of pay
ten percent of pay fifteen percent of
pay I think those are benchmarks that
individuals can easily get their hands
around so it might be worth thinking
about something lower five percent for
younger workers something higher maybe
ten percent for older workers I
understand it but keep in mind we're
trying to make this as simple as
possible and I'm a big fan of simplicity
okay but I hear you that I understand
that a question for you and I'll just
ask everyone else here we sometimes hear
the argument that automatic enrollment
doesn't really boost savings because
people make up for the lost disposable
income by reducing other forms of
savings have any of you looked at
whether or not automatic enrollment
crowds out other forms of savings so
I've been trying to do a study that
would answer this questions for years
and it's really hard to get the date the
data to do that well the little evidence
that we have suggest that to the extent
there is crowd out it probably isn't
that big I have a former graduate
student who's done some research on
savings behavior by members of the
military and the thrift savings plan and
he finds that financial education
programs that have substantially
increased savings in the TSP have had no
adverse impact for example on the amount
of
credit that military members have
outstanding so he's finding no crowd out
there there's a study by my colleagues
John Friedman and Raj Chetty at Harvard
looking at Denmark where you can get
much better data the Scandinavians
aren't so concerned about privacy and
when they look at automatic savings
programs they find very little crowd out
on other parts of the balance sheet
either so I think it's a legitimate
concern but I think most of the evidence
out there suggests that certainly it's
not one for one offset any other
thoughts on the crowd out at all miss
McCarthy er yeah i would offer I i we
don't have research to support exciting
the complexity of getting at that what's
happening outside the plan is difficult
but I think what's really important on
the automatic enrollment is recognition
of the significant impact it has in
getting participants actually into the
plan so our our enrollment rate
participation rate across our customers
is sixty-seven percent with automatic
enrollment it's eighty eight percent
well so it's a very very powerful
distinction that in and of itself is so
dramatic that you know it's hard for me
to think it's it's creating a big
distraction with other savings vehicles
asansol before my time runs out quickly
a lot of people don't have traditional
40-hour week jobs part-time workers
temporary workers caregivers Oh what do
we need to do to make sure people with
non-traditional employment arrangements
have access easy access to a retirement
plan well I think we need options and
opportunities for people to save at work
I mean a lot of part-time workers are
just not eligible for for benefits and
it's been true I don't know that that's
ever going to change I don't think
requiring employers to do that tax
lawyers tell me all the ways you can
fudge those rules so I I just think we
need ways for people wherever they were
to save and we don't have that I mean
for half the workforce well again that's
something we're looking at in developing
this us a retirement fund
make it simple make it easy so that
there's not a burden on employers for
part-time employees or employees that
come in and out of the system all the
time where they wouldn't whether the
employer would not have a fiduciary
responsibility would not have to operate
a plan or anything like that so any any
other advice you have Annette please let
us know yeah well we look forward to
seeing the clan role senator Alexander
mr. chairman sense senator Enzi has been
working on this with you for a while I'd
like for him to have the first questions
Thank You mr. chairman and thank you for
working on this it really is important I
want to thank the panel for their
tremendous suggestions I mean your your
testimony is just packed with ideas and
that's led to a lot of questions which
are more technical nature than all
attempt while doing my questions I
appreciate the emphasis on
auto-enrolment versus perhaps a mandate
and I appreciate the comments to about
the school's needing to do financial
literacy I've looked at a number of
schools to see what they're doing and
I'm very disturbed that when they
provide them with the money that they're
going to learn to budget they leave out
the fact that their social security and
medicare taken out and the possibility
of any kind of savings that they might
add to that so I'm hoping that that that
that will change for dr. Madren and miss
McCarthy have you done anything on on
the plans whether it would make a
difference if the deferred mount was a
401 K versus a Roth would that make a
difference in in this auto enrollment
and contribution so the the limited
research that I've done on regular
versus Roth savings accounts suggest
that people behave very similarly in
both types of savings plans which
suggests that the Roth option might
actually lead to higher levels of
long-run wealth accumulation because the
taxes
have been taken out on the front end but
truthfully we need much more research
into that question mr. karthi I would
agree with that Senator it senator Enzi
it's a very good question we haven't
done extensive research we're seeing
powerful results with both the Roth IRA
excuse me yet the Roth plan in the
ability that that provides for
incremental savings coupled with auto
but I don't have distinctive research at
this point well I'm hoping both staying
in effect as possibilities one of the
things I'm really concerned about is the
amount of regulation that we have and
the possibility for liability when
they're doing that that's the the two
things that small businessman tell me
are the things that keep them from going
into this and that I'm an accountant I
used to do the accounting for primarily
401k and then do the fairness testing
and that that gets into whether the top
executives are getting paid more and
saving more versus the other people do
you have any suggestion suggestions for
ways that the regulations could be made
simpler perhaps for particularly small
business the mr. Moss landrieu I think
you were relating to some of that
certainly regulation is a difficult
difficult thing for employers to deal
with especially around fiduciary
responsibility I think one of the more
creative and perhaps it could have
unintended positive consequences is
lifting the fiduciary burden from the
employer and putting it elsewhere I
think might lead to portability
possibilities that are difficult today
for for people to manage you change jobs
but the fiduciary responsibility we
could somehow ease that simplify it even
lifted from the employer I would go a
long way towards simplifying simplifying
the ability of employers to provide for
the plans and then also simplifying
portability by participants and main
they might not cash out those benefits
the way they do today when they
terminate employment it were easier for
those benefits to be portable
I really appreciate the portability
anybody else want to comment on the
regulation if I could just add again
simplification is key in every aspect of
this conversation from a lip from a
regulatory perspective our experience
shows that in smaller plans as you're
pointing out there adoption is very
often avoided as a result of the
regulatory requirement so I think
looking at safe harbors and how to
simplify those I'm looking at the
fiduciary responsibilities the
disclosures are often very onerous and
it all drives costs for the employer
which will cause them to step back and
not offer the benefit so simplicity
there's a very real opportunity there I
think without walking away from the
importance of the goals looking to be
achieved with the regulations anybody
else I've also got a bill that would
allow pooling of small businesses so
they could have one administrator for a
number of them I mean it's still
individual accounts and that's what
allows the portability if they move to a
different different job which improves
the enhancement of this and Senator Kohl
and i also have a bill that deals with
the sum of the leakage problems so that
people have an opportunity to put it
back in particularly if they leave 11
business and my time has expired I thank
the chair thank you very much senator
Enzi and again i'm sure i didn't tell
you all this but cinder NZ was chair of
this committee and shepherded through
the pension protection act so he is one
of our resident experts on this whole
issue so I'm delighted to have have him
as a partner in this effort as you know
we recognize people in order of
appearance here so this will be it'll be
a senator Warren then back to Senator
Alexander and Alexander senator Murphy
senator Isakson senator Baldwin senator
burr
senator Franken the senator Casey in
that order so we recognize that Senator
Warren thank you very much mr. chairman
and I want to offer my thanks to the
panel a very much miss counsel for the
work you're doing an education for all
of you the commitment that the companies
have made to trying to educate clients
and the work you've done in research it
it seems to me I read your testimony I
agree with Senator Enzi it's full of
good ideas good thoughts and primarily
based around how we might do better with
employer-sponsored plans and it's
pulling people in I went through all of
them the notion of changing opt-out
increasing the default amount the pre
commitments to growth and you're very
creative plan doctor made rien of
changing how the employer calculates the
incentive to get people to to stay in
but I also notice in your testimony that
you all to one extent or another talk
about incentivizing the employers or
encouraging the employers I noticed the
different verbs we use and that I'm
mindful of senator Alexander's point
that on the one hand we could require
the employers to participate senator
Alexander says but this creates
complications for small businesses so
the question I really have is can you
fill in that part of what you're talking
about in your testimony we don't have
employees who will participate in these
plans if we don't have employers who are
offering these plans so how do we get
more employers to offer these plans what
are what are the options available to us
and how effective will they be mrs.
McCarthy would you like to start yes
thank you I think it comes down to the
discussion we had around simplification
because the for smaller employers one of
the biggest inhibitors is the cost of
administration in the fiduciary
responsibility and complexity that goes
along with administer the plans so if we
can streamline some of the requirements
and accountability of them I think we
would have naturally have better
adoption and then when you get into the
actual experience there there are ways
to offer very simple plans that reduce
the administrative costs as well dr. Bay
dream yeah let me completely agree with
that I think there needs to be a very
simple option for employers that needs
to have you know no you know no
regulatory requirements that they need
to go very minimal regulatory
requirements limited fiduciary
responsibility something simple and
straightforward and then to the extent
you can pinky back that with something
else that employers are already doing so
it doesn't add an administrative burden
that would also help so for example if
I'm if small employers are filing the
tax payments on behalf of their
employees quarterly couple the
contributions to the savings plan with
what they're already doing to pay their
quarterly taxes instead of instituting a
new regular ritory requirement that they
need to do these contributions in some
other way shape or form at some other
point in time anything to minimize the
administrative burden and the regulatory
burden will be extremely helpful you
could also think about providing a
modest tax incentive to companies if
they offer a savings plan so if you
offer the savings plan will give you a
break on your employer taxes very
valuable um mr. Moss slander I would
agree with everything Julian Bridget
said the the art of regulation if you
would I think is important there are you
know out of the Pension Protection Act
there additional auditing and reporting
requirements which are probably very
good things but we also had fee
disclosure which at the plan sponsor
level was valuable at the participants
the opposite of that and we all spent a
lot of money a lot of time a lot of
energy to mail out and send out fee
disclosure information to participants
who you know in the first place there
minimally engaged in the plan they're
not going to be interested in the
expense ratio of every fund that's
offered under that plan so that was the
kind of regulation well intended but in
the
really didn't have the impact that it
had you know isn't designed to have
something kind of trying to manage
necessary regulation with that's not you
know regulation that's not really going
to have a big impact isn't just echoing
what Bridget and Julia said is it
important all right miss council is this
going to get us there by making the
plans simpler I think so I difference
great people so very valuable thank you
very much I appreciate I'd like to
pursue continue doctor professor
Warren's senator warns line of
questioning because I think it's a very
very helpful helpful when I i remember
in order to be the governor of tennessee
i walked across the state many years ago
and when i was out there with nobody to
talk to but cows that were along the
road i was thinking that if i got
elected what if i could make a tax form
or some sort of list that i could hand
to somebody who wanted to start a
business and say from the state's point
of view this is everything we care about
you know these are all the taxes all the
regulations all the rules a complete
list of them if you do all these things
you don't have to worry about us the
state anymore of course when i got into
office i never was able to do that you
know it but still simplicity i think is
pretty big here we've we've seen i think
that the law that was passed a few years
ago has taught us some things about the
value of a default position about
auto-enrolment about automatic
escalations and and and we know that
financial literacy is is not at a high
level among a lot of us even if we spent
a lot of time in it these things can get
very confusing we don't want to take
everyone's freedom away to make their
his or her own decision about this but
the automatic enrollment at a or
automatic changes or default positions
that better reflect the reality of what
an individual needs seen me be one
very promising further step we could
take and using your advice about what
that should be is one step but I'm very
intrigued by this simple simple form
because that's exactly what I'm thinking
and I wonder what what happened if I
invited you to write it for us and
submit it to us I mean let's say you're
about to go into business and your look
I mean dr. Madren this is what you do
you study all this stuff you have for 15
years you know what's going on better
than we do and why don't you write for
us a simple plan that we could put into
law so if I'm starting a business if I
have a small business i'm already paying
my FICA tax and I'm got the minimum wage
I've got this i'm worried about the
health care law and somebody says to me
well why don't you do something about
retirement I'm going to say I you know I
might not make any money this year but
if it's simple if it's so simple that I
could do it and it's good for my
employees and and and good to do maybe
we could do that and we could make it a
pilot program you know we don't have to
do it for everybody in the whole country
at once we could take a simple point so
I would invite each of you if you would
like to to submit to me or to us your
idea of a simple plan free of anything
you can think of to get free of and
still make it responsibility that would
encourage and enterprise to start or
offer a voluntary plan that would
promote the savings levels that you
think are appropriate now I'd like to
ask one question about that if you were
to do it would you do it for any
business or would you do it for a small
business and if so how would you define
the enterprise that you would that you
would do such a thing for
anyone have a response well I'll start
out by saying I'm gonna go back to my
class next monday and i'm going to give
them your challenge and then we'll see
what they can come up with well no I'm
quite seriously they're likely to their
likely to come up with some excellent
ideas give them the idea of say look
you're going into business and you've
got a lot of other things to do how
would you do this and it would be very
helpful to us last year the the CFPB
held some sort of a competition senator
Warren would know better about this to
redesign the mortgage disclosure forms
to it and enlist you know unless the the
great thinkers in society and see if if
the consumer financial protection bureau
would actually do that it would it would
double my and my my it would increase my
appreciation of the agency which is not
very high right now but the mortgage the
mortgage disclosure form is a good
example of what we're talking about all
of these regulations are well intended
that mean we don't sit up here and say
we want to do something bad to somebody
we all have good ideas but they pile up
and then when you're down here and you
know getting alone anybody who's got a
mortgage loan lady knows it's absurd
nobody reads it nobody can read it or
understand it so you really have less
disclosure but because of more
regulation so so rather than complain
about the regulation let's just start
from scratch and and say what would what
could we do let's follow up senator
Warren's comment and mine and that of
others here all of you seem to think
simplicity makes a big difference I'm
sure that's true any comment on any of
that by any of you thank you for the
opportunity we look forward to it with a
lot of good ideas will bring them forth
thank you very much senator Alexander
and now senator Murphy thank you very
much mr. chairman what an important
hearing just one quick thought and then
one or two questions you know to my mind
the most important barrier to savings is
not simplicity or regulations it's it's
stagnant wages fact is that the average
workers making four percent less in real
wages than they were
in 1970 they haven't had any gains since
2005 meanwhile you know all sorts of
other costs are going up health care
went from a percent of your budget to
eighteen percent of your budget in the
last 40 years and so it's tough to save
if you don't make any more than you did
10 or 20 years ago and I and I know
we're not going to tackle that in the
context of a bill on pensions but I just
think it's worth noting that if this
Congress doesn't tackle the issue of
stagnant wages there's there's not a lot
we can do around the edges to try to
make money appear out of nowhere that
being said younger generations today
still think they're living in their
parents world I mean they still think
that if they go to work that they're
just going to end up getting taken care
of they probably rely too much on
Medicare and Social Security but I think
they just also don't understand how much
the obligation is now shifted to them
and mr. mas cylinder I was really glad
that you brought up the lifetime income
disclosure act and this is a bill that
Senator Isakson and Senator Bingaman
support I'm hopeful to join you senator
this session and reintroducing it but I
just wanted to ask you to follow up on
your support for that piece of
legislation this is a pretty innovative
idea to just sort of put right in front
of workers especially younger workers
what the true annuity benefit of their
savings is and i guess i'll i'll ask a
devil's advocate question about a bill
that i support but given that these
forms sort of come to you with lots of
information already and you know a lot
of workers don't pay too much attention
to them in the first place what do we
think the confidence is that adding
another number which will be a pretty
startling number the amount of money are
actually going to get if you continue on
your current savings trajectory what
what kind of confidence do we have that
might actually change people's savings
patterns a couple of things i'm not sure
that young people are as confident that
they're going to be quote taken care of
i think there is some skepticism among
young people about the viability and
what there will be in social security
and like for them at the time they get
older so i think there is
and I think there's some research that
shows that younger people are a little
less or a little bit more inclined to
consider saving for retirement the Attic
ref we long for years and years and
years we always send even before there
were quarterly statement requirements we
sent people a projection a statement at
the end of each year that projected
their income and it wasn't it wasn't
important that they looked at it every
year it was important that they got it
every year and over time we believe that
the the presenting them with that income
figure as opposed to just an
accumulation figure created a mindset
toward lifetime retirement income
security and is one of the reasons we
believe we've seen a lot more
annuitization in the higher education
market than you see in the profit-making
sector and part of its the products that
are used in that in that marketplace but
it's also we believe because we
presented this and the employers have
reinforced the fact that the plan is for
retirement income and this was a
reinforcing mechanism to as a mindset
issue more than as an actual you know
should I say it does help people save
more but it also gets the moon in the
mode of thinking this is not something I
cash out when I'm done it's something I
receive income from and then one
additional question to build on this
line of conversation around simplicity I
think it's incredibly important and
we've sort of been talking about it with
respect to simplicity as it relates to
employers and maybe I'll direct this to
Professor Mandarin what about the
barriers to savings from a employee
perspective I mean it's dizzying the the
verbiage surrounding retirement savings
today and what do we know about the
barriers presented to people who want to
put money away when they're confronted
with this absolute multitude of words
and phrases and vehicles that are
available to them yes the alphabet soup
of retirement savings plan options in
the u.s. you should have come to my
class yesterday this is exactly what we
talked about I I think the the big
challenge is not so much that people
don't want to save but they
don't know how to do it and it's a it's
a combination of a lot of people don't
have really high levels of financial
literacy they're not you know they're
not comfortable with choosing at Harvard
University up until a year and a half
ago we had 259 different investment
options that's a lot of that's a lot of
choices to sort through if you're trying
to decide how to invest your money and I
think that's the key reason why
automatic enrollment is so successful
automatic enrolment is the extreme form
of simplification you don't have to do
anything if you're if you want to be
saving and in fact the action needs to
be taken by individuals who don't want
to save they're the ones who have to opt
out of the plan and the fact that when
opt-out happens it happens immediately
it's not like people discover a year
later my employers taking money out of
my paycheck I didn't want that to happen
I want to opt out that to me is
indicative of kind of a strong desire
for most people to save and the
simplification is really key even in
plans without automatic enrolment we
found that if you provide a simplified
option to sign up for the plan think of
a postcard that has a box on it check
this box and we'll enroll you in the
savings plan and we've picked an
investment allocation for you even
initiatives like that can substantially
increase savings plan participation so I
think the simplification is key for both
the employee and the employer Thank you
Thank You sector senator Alexander and I
want to memorialize here publicly in
front of everybody including those on
television that Senator Murphy I'm
delighted to accept you as the
replacement for jeff bingaman as the
lead co-sponsor they act looking looking
forward to it and I appreciate the plug
very much and I appreciate the the
comments of mr. Moss Lander regarding
drawed the drawdown face because we are
always talking about the accumulation
phase in beginning the process but
taking the money out the wrong way can
leave people without any retirement
while they're still alive and I think
it's very important that we focus on
that education ms mccarthy i want to ask
you a question
I think you said in your testimony that
participants who seek guidance take
action and have better outcomes is that
correct absolutely correct the
Department of Labor the last two years
and I understand continuing this year is
trying very much to change the
definition of the term fiduciary would
you give me your opinion on if that
change takes place what effect that
would have on people getting education
in terms of retirement savings yes thank
you for the opportunity to talk about it
I fear that it would have a very
dramatic effect on sponsors or partners
vendors record keepers ability to
provide guidance to participants we've
done a tremendous amount of research
amongst our the participants that we
service to understand what drives their
behavior enrolling in the plan not
enrolling in the plan and one of the key
key dynamics is again simplicity as
we've been talking about auto enroll has
been dramatic but simply not knowing
what to do and when we think about
guidance guidance really boils down to
help it's as simple as that so the
prospect of not allowing providers to
help participants engage in their plan
well I have confidence have a dramatic
impact in this issue we're talking about
today and it won't be advantageous I
appreciate your testimony very much
because I feel exactly the same way I
think education and transparency is just
invaluable and people making the right
decision for themselves and every time
we put a barrier between them getting
that good information we're causing bad
things to happen that's not the intent
but that's the result and that brings me
to miss Hansel's commentary particularly
about women and second career women and
divorce and things of that nature I ran
a company for 22 years that I were all
my workers all my sales people were
independent contractors I had a thousand
of them and almost all of them were
second career women divorced women are
women over 50 years old who came back to
have a career in real estate out of some
life driven necessity most of them had
not saved or they had did not have a
husband who had saved or worse were not
prepared for retirement when it might
come which would be in 10 to 15 years
but because i used independent
contractors as sales people in my
organization the IRS prohibition against
me providing any information or any help
in savings made it made it impossible
for me to help them which brings me to
the point of the fiduciary and
everything else we probably need a
one-page list of all the things that we
do up here that are negative towards
people starting their retirement savings
either in the tax code in IRS rules and
regulations or what the Department of
Labor might do those are not the
intended consequences but they are the
consequences they were with me I finally
and I don't know if it's still true the
independent contractor test used to be a
10-point tested IRS one of which was you
could not provide information vehicles
or anything else you could direct them
to an IRA set but somebody else had to
be the administrator and the advisor
could you do that for us could you with
the people you deal with in the trials
and tribulations you have of people
having actually access to that would you
give us a list of all those things that
we require that in the end are negative
towards formation of capital for savings
and retirement and no I know that but
you're you're very experienced with
exactly the type of people we're
concerned about I did it again sorry I I
think what you're saying is that you
actually directed people towards some
kind of a retirement plan well I right
but you weren't supposed to I know I
didn't know yeah
oh you didn't know I hoped everything
else I could not direct them to a plan I
could advise them they ought to seek
information but I couldn't give them the
direction or anything else I just would
tell them you really ought to go take
care of this they say will you help me i
say i can write and that that's often
what helps people get retirement income
because somebody will direct them to
what they should be doing whether
they're especially if they don't have
auto-enrolment so well send the reason I
mentioned senator Harkin made the
statement about nontraditional he called
them non-traditional employees with the
Affordable Care Act and some of the
other things that are happening they're
going to be more independent contractors
as workers in this country are thinking
more part-time workers in this country
and it's going to be more and more
difficult with some of the prohibitions
that are in the law now and regulation
for them to get the right type of
information right here is all of you for
your tennis florian senator Baldwin
thank you and I want to also thank the
Chairman and ranking member for holding
this important hearing and our witnesses
for testifying I'm deeply concerned
about some of the statistics from my
home state of Wisconsin I the number of
citizens who rely solely on Social
Security as a source of income once they
retire figures shared by AARP suggest
that twenty-eight percent of Wisconsin
Heights who receive Social Security have
reported that this benefit is their only
income and two out of three Wisconsin
Heights age 65 or older reported that
Social Security makes up more than half
of their monthly income so the figures
and trends are certainly troubling I
also appreciate my colleague senator
Murphy for talking about some of the
issues that we're not grappling with
here today stagnant wages etc as we look
at the health of our middle class and I
just think about the hallmarks of
middle-class status and one of them in
my mind is retirement security and of
course we're discussing the fact that
that's in jeopardy for some
I miss hounds all I want to appreciate
your testimony this is the week in which
we celebrate the fourth anniversary of
the signing of the lilly Ledbetter Act
into law and I were hopeful that that
act along with future legislation that
we're working on will begin to decrease
the wage gap that exists between men and
women but until that happens obviously
it's clear that women are less and
therefore that affects the capability of
saving for retirement a report by the
Joint Economic Committee released this
week chaired by our colleague on this
committee senator Casey states that for
women over 65 years of age social
security accounts for two-thirds of
their total income well for men over the
age of 65 it's roughly fifty four
percent in your written testimony you
reference the importance of the National
Education and Research Center on women
and retirement planning in educating
women on how to plan for retirement it's
a program funded by the administration
on Aging so one quick I it's my
understanding that if sequestration
proceeds the administration aging would
see a decrease in its discretionary
budget of about a hundred and twenty 1
million dollars in 2013 alone so I
wonder if you can discuss generally the
importance of this program in promoting
retirement savings and whether you
believe or have heard the sequestration
would have an impact on the on the
initiative yeah yes it will have an
impact on all of the programs that are
at the administration on Aging and a lot
of these programs are minimally funded
but have such a big reach and the way
we've actually operated the center was
to train trainers all over the country
we've actually worked with the wider
opportunities for women and
are people in Wisconsin wider
opportunities just came out with their
report last week I don't know if you saw
that and what it does is it sort of
shows what people over 65 need to live
on in various states and cities and I
don't remember Wisconsin but i know that
for single women it's anywhere from
19,000 to 29,000 that's just minimal
just rent he you know all of those
things that are absolutely necessary so
I think you know everyone says I work
with a lot of organizations and everyone
will say well you know we need one on
one especially for the you know like the
Latina groups and we need one on one for
everyone really I mean that's what
everybody wants and then probably you
sort of know that from your research as
well I think what's really important is
you know senior centers places where
where people can actually come for help
finra's got this great project on
libraries and there aren't that many of
them there's about I think 25 they've
funded I've been to a number of them
doing programs with them they're
incredible so there are ways that we
could do this but there you know there's
no coordination no reach nationally
except for this little you know these
little programs that the National
Council on Aging does a great initiative
as well so I don't know what will happen
after sequestration thank you
senator Franken thank you this topic
brings up so many so many subjects that
about what is happening to the workforce
what's happening to what kind of jobs
people are going to do what kind of
companies people are going to have in
the future that you know it's not we're
changing and people are going to have a
lot more different jobs as we go into
the future that the long pass where you
had the same job for for your entire
career that so that's an issue that I
wonder about is and not only do people
change change jobs companies exists for
sometimes shorter times and and so was
the effect of that was the effect of
people may be having 20 jobs in their
career or 30 jobs in their career or
going from one thing to another and what
is the effect what happens when the
place here you have your pension goes
out of business okay but you can speak
to that well I mean I could speak to
that for a minute because it happened to
me so I have a frozen benefit at the
pbgc so I work for a company for 16
years and there went the DB plan at some
point it was frozen and then went to the
PBGC so what you do is people are going
to have to cull together many of these
different benefits wherever they go and
look for them I imagine your benefit
under the PB pension benefit guaranty
corporation is is going to be a lot less
than you had expected yeah was frozen
for 25 years so a lot less I think Julia
can probably talk best about what
happens from the plan administration
Stan
point what I'd like to point out is I
think the fact that people are changing
jobs so often really highlights the
importance of getting employers to set
higher default contribution rates and to
address the problems of leakage because
those are both issues that are really
tied to job changing if you think of a
system where companies have automatic
enrollment and they enroll you at a low
contribution rate that escalates over
time and you're changing jobs every year
you're always getting restarted at a low
contribution rate and you never get up
to a high enough contribution rate to
really set aside money for retirement so
that's a key reason why we need a higher
default contribution rate with automatic
enrollment and then we know that a lot
of the leakage from the system is
generated when people change jobs and
suddenly they're presented with this
option to leave the money in the plan to
roll it over to another plant or aha I
can take the money out and do something
with it today and that's when the
leakage is the leakage is occurring so
we need to think about ways to
discourage employers or discourage
employees from doing that and to the
extent some of them may need money
because they're unemployed to limit the
the extent to which they're taking money
out of the plan really important I know
you want to speak with McCarthy I but I
just want to put a bookmark in my head
here because that all goes to financial
literacy but go ahead it absolutely does
we have I agree with everything Bridget
saying it does come back to financial
literacy and education on the
implication of compounding there are a
number of different studies out there
that talk about how long that these next
generations will stay in their roles
ranging from 10 years to 20 years as you
said very very different than the
environment that we've grown up in
portability is incredibly important so
the ability to take your benefit and
consolidate it roll it together so which
you start to think about retirement
projections you really have a
comprehensive view of what you've
accumulated and you continue to build on
that we have study that shows age 22 or
participants aged 20 to 24 51% of them
don't engage in the planet at all so if
there's a portion that just simply
aren't engaging
forty-four percent of this population
cash out so that's that's the problem
and they're just accumulating if your
auto amad three percent maybe they get
to four percent you cash them out they
go on to the next company they will
never accumulate retirement wealth I
kind of want to talk thank you i want to
talk just touch base on a couple things
on financial literacy we're also the
Education Committee where are the Health
Committee where the labor where you are
the pension committee or the education
we need to have financial literacy
taught in our schools and you were given
a I forgot who assigned you that was a
Senator Enzi who gave you a big
assignment I I would have another set of
your students work on a math curriculum
that uses all the issues in retirement
to teach math but also teach financial
literacy at the same time because we I
remember we used to have shop and homak
and homak is home economics and so that
is the place there is a place for us to
teach to have kids understand the world
that they're going into so they don't
get in trouble with credit cards so they
don't buy a house with a bad contract so
that it takes some of the pressure off
the CFPB you know you know and and then
the other thing I just want to mention
is annuities you know people i was i was
on the Special Committee on Aging and I
had something it just shocked me and
then I guess in retrospect it isn't that
shocking that people actually when asked
how long do they think they're going to
live under estimated
and so you know we need to get people
into annuities we need to do that was so
that they don't outlive their their
savings thank you thanks senator Franken
I want to thank the the four witnesses
has been very very very helpful we'd
like to leave the record open for 10
days senator Harkin had to step out so
I'm going to conclude the hearing but
several of us may have follow-up
questions that we'd like to ask you and
if you'd be kind enough to respond to
them I think you can tell from the level
of interest in your comments it will
surely pay close attention you've gotten
too big assignments here senator Franken
and I I this is encouraging to me
because the legislation that passed in
2006 seems to have had some good effects
and we've gotten some some good
information that about about ways to to
to meet senator Harkins goal which is to
narrow the gap between what Americans
ought to be saving for retirement and
what they do save for retirement from my
own point of view it seems to me that a
good deal more work needs to be done on
complexity legalese and liability and
that there you know that this is a
committee where we supposedly have very
different ideological views but I think
you've heard some common suggestion here
that rather than taking off regulations
approaching it by taking off regulations
we might try a model that starts from
scratch with the objective of making it
easier for business enterprises in our
changing country where apparently more
Americans are going to be independent
contractors not full-time employees may
be part-time employees Boyer's how do we
make it easier for employers of any kind
to offer savings at and to do it in a
way that closes the gap that Senator
Harkin call this hearing about so thank
you very much for for coming look
forward to hearing back from you and I
suspect you'll be hearing from several
of us with specific questions hearings
adjourned
thank you
at the whole Mexican
No
you've been watching a Senate hearing
looking at pension and retirement issues
if you missed any of this live program
you can watch it anytime online at C
span org slash video library with